The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Welcome, back.
Today we're going to break
the mold of these one
degree of freedom
systems in a major way.
We're going to go to two
degree of freedom systems.
There are two sort of canonical
underactuated systems.
In fact, I'd say that the
field of underactuated robotics
spends most of its
time thinking about
a few canonical
underactuated problems.
The two we're going
to talk about today
are the Acrobot and
the cart-pole systems.
The Acrobot is a
two-link robotic arm.
The only thing
special about it--
it's operating in
the vertical plane.
The only thing that
makes it special
is that somebody forgot to
put a motor at the shoulder.
So you've got a motor at
the elbow and no motor
at the shoulder.
It's called the Acrobot
because you can--
it's a little bit like an
acrobat on a high bar that
has to spin around
and do tricks,
even though they can't produce
much torque with their wrist
and they have to do it
all with their waist.
The other one, the
cart-pole system,
you've probably seen it in
an intro controls course.
In our 6003 and our
Signals and Systems
course at the end of the year,
they bring in a cart-pole
and do a little demonstration.
It's a cart with--
I made it a simple
pendulum, since we
thought a lot about the
simple pendulums, on the cart.
You're allowed to push
the cart sideways.
But there's only a pin joint
here holding the pendulum up.
So you have to the
balance the pendulum
with the cart by
moving the cart.
Now, in our intro
controls courses,
they do linear control.
At the top, they do
some simple modeling,
some pole placement in 6003.
So they start it near the top.
It stays near the top.
They actually-- they put a wine
glass or something on the top.
They put a Christmas
tree on the top.
They do all these things, but
they never start it from here
because then the
nonlinearity kicks in.
And that's why we
need this course.
We've got to-- that's
a harder problem.
So we're going to do the full
Cart-Pole starting today.
And we'll finish it on Thursday.
So the equations of
motion of both of those
are quite easy to derive.
They take a half a page,
and they're in the notes.
Both of them are nicely
described by the manipulator
equations that I introduced
in the first lecture.
So let's work in the
manipulator equation form.
So if you remember,
I said that most
of the systems we
care about can be
described by these equations.
It happens that both
of these systems
are sort of trivially
underactuated.
They've got one actuator
and one passive joint,
so B turns out to be--
well, I've actually got it
to be 0 and 1 for the Acrobot
and 1, 0 for the cart-pole.
But they're both sort
of the standard form.
So the first thing I
think that everybody
does with these systems
and that we have to discuss
is, let's see if we can
make it balance at the top.
The task in both
of these cases is
to take the system from some
arbitrary initial condition
and get it up to the
top, and balance.
It turns out that, even though
the systems are underactuated,
you can do that.
Just to show you the--
to help your
intuition here, this
is some Acrobot
video from the web.
They have a belt
drive going down
to their elbow motor
and a big motor
up here, like very
big motor up here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
And if you're willing to
sort of pump energy up
through the second
link, then you can--
- Oh!
RUSS TEDRAKE: They
were very excited.
[LAUGHTER] Then you can
add energy to the system,
get it to swing around.
And then the cool thing
is, you can stabilize it
at the top, which is
actually pretty surprising.
So this one took however many
pumps, got itself the top,
balanced, they said, oh!
So in this class, we're
going to do better.
So this is just a teaser.
But here, if you were to take
your optimal control tools
and try to solve the same
problem, the exact same system.
Now it's in MATLAB.
But we're going to do a
lot better by thinking
about sort of minimum
time or even LQR solutions
to get to the top.
I think that's pretty elegant.
So single pump,
and then it's up.
And of course, it will depend
on your torque limits and all
these things, but I think we
can do very elegant control
on these kind of problems.
OK, so I want to
start by thinking
about balancing at the top.
So it's not obvious, if I've
got a system with a motor
at the elbow and no
motor at the shoulder,
that I could balance at the top.
You'd think that, if I
fall with my elbow motor,
I've got nothing
immediately to correct it.
So how the heck do I stabilize
that fixed point at the top?
Well, it turns out you can.
And let's look at that.
You've probably seen
linearization before.
It turns out, if you're
linearizing things
from the manipulated
equations, it's pretty elegant.
So I'm going to do
that quickly here.
So our system that we're working
with here is just an x dot.
It equals f of u in
state-space form.
But it happens because it's
from the manipulator equation,
that if we choose
x to be q, q dot,
like we always
do, then f of x, u
has this sort of block matrix,
a block vector form here,
which is--
q double dot is now H
inverse q, Bu minus Cq
dot minus G. I just solve
that for q double dot.
We know that H is--
an inertial matrix, it's always
uniformly positive definite.
So for all q's, it's
positive definite.
So I can take its inverse,
and I get that solution for q
double that.
So the derivative of x is--
this is q dot, sorry.
It looks like a
line, but it's a dot.
And now we want to think
about linearizing that system
around a fixed point.
The way we're going
to do that, of course,
is taking a Taylor expansion.
I'm going to take
my x dot and say
it's approximately equal to
f of x at the fixed point, u
of x at the fixed point,
plus partial f, partial x,
with x evaluated
at the fixed point,
u evaluated at the fixed
point, times x minus x star,
plus partial f, partial u,
evaluated at the fixed point.
And it turns out
for these equations,
at a fixed point, that's really
not a hard thing to compute.
So can we do that quickly?
So what's this
term, first of all?
AUDIENCE: 0.
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's
going to be 0, right?
If we're at a fixed
point, then the derivative
at that fixed point better be 0.
So this guy just disappears.
Partial f, partial x
we'll look at real quick.
Partial f, partial u turns
out to be not too hard.
Let's do a partial
f, partial u first.
It's even easier.
So this is a vector, right?
So I'm going to end up with,
in general, a matrix of here,
which contains the
terms partial q
dot, roughly, partial u,
and partial q double dot,
partial u.
So what's partial
q dot, partial u?
AUDIENCE: 0.
RUSS TEDRAKE: 0, right?
Partial q double
dot, partial u, well,
that turns out to be--
even though there's
a lot of matrices
flying around here
with possibly nonlinear
things inside,
everything's linear in u.
So that's actually
pretty easy to write too.
That turns out to be H inverse
B. And this whole thing is
going to be evaluated at our--
u doesn't matter in this
case-- but evaluated
at our fixed point.
OK, what about
partial f, partial x?
So now x is a bigger thing.
So I'm going to have partial
q dot, partial q here.
This is sort of a block
matrix form I'm using here--
partial q dot,
partial q dot here,
and then partial q double
dot, partial q, partial q
double dot, partial q dot.
What's this?
AUDIENCE: 0.
RUSS TEDRAKE: 0.
What's this one?
AUDIENCE: 1.
RUSS TEDRAKE: 1, or
more generally, I, yeah.
q double dot, partial q--
we need to use our chain rule.
This is, something
depends on q times
something else
that depends on q.
So it's going to be partial
H inverse, partial q,
times Bu minus Cq dot minus
G, plus H inverse, partial
of that whole inside.
And H is potentially
a little messy.
H inverse is
probably more messy.
But it turns out this is going
to be very simple, again,
for us.
So I claim that this
term at the fixed point
has also got to be 0.
Do you buy that?
Yep.
This thing has got to
equal H, q double dot.
H is positive definite.
So for q double dot to be
0, this had better be 0.
So that whole thing goes to 0.
So this term-- or we don't
have to do partial H inverse,
partial q--
great.
And this one, again, is
actually pretty simple.
In the very first
lecture, I did use B
as potentially a function of q.
But for these examples,
it certainly isn't.
It's just a constant.
So this doesn't have
any dependence on q.
C does depend on q.
G does depend on q.
But at the fixed
point, q dot had better
be 0, if it's a fixed point.
So the only term that
actually survives out
of this whole potentially
scary thing is--
yeah, good-- is negative H
inverse, partial G, partial q.
Take the derivative
with respect to q dot.
Again, this term is 0.
So no matter--
H inverse, partial q
dot doesn't matter.
And then what in here
depends on q dot?
Well, C depends on q dot,
both directly and internally.
So we end up with partial--
so H inverse, partial C, partial
q dot, times q dot, plus--
I'll do the whole
thing as minus here--
plus C. But again, q dot
is 0 at the fixed point,
so it ends up-- this whole scary
thing reduces to H inverse C.
AUDIENCE: So G is
[INAUDIBLE] of [? theta? ?]
RUSS TEDRAKE:
That's correct, yep.
Those are our
gravitational terms, yeah.
OK, so this whole potentially
scary thing works out
to be 0, I, negative H
inverse, partial G, partial q,
negative H inverse, C. OK?
There's a lot of beauty in
the manipulator equations.
It's a very nice middle ground
between sort of any arbitrary
nonlinear system, but
it's got enough structure
that you can play a lot
of tricks like this.
And often, things simplify.
So I actually think it's
a beautiful representation
that we're lucky to
have in robotics.
OK, now I've got this form.
That's a linear
system here, right?
I've got-- if I just call
this thing A and this thing B,
then I've got x equals
Ax plus Bu here.
And if you prefer to
really make it linear,
then let's define x bar
to be x minus x star,
u bar to be u minus u star,
to put the origin at the fixed
point.
Oops.
Now, x bar dot is
just x dot minus--
this thing's-- that's
0, so it's just x dot.
So I could equally write
this as Ax bar plus Bu bar.
OK, so given the manipulator
equations for the Acrobot,
for the cart-pole, it's trivial
to find a local approximation
of those dynamics which is
valid around the fixed point
we're trying to stabilize.
And if I have that, then I could
play some of the linear control
games that we started with.
So the first thing to try,
let's do LQR at the top.
It turns out LQR at the
top just works really well.
It's not too
surprising, I guess.
Actually, before we do
LQR, let me take a minute
and actually decide
if we should--
if it's proper to do LQR.
So there's a
condition in LQR that
had to be met in that
derivation that I threw at you.
If the infinite horizon cost,
that integral wasn't bounded,
if your system didn't
get to the origin,
then the LQR cost
would be infinite,
and the LQR derivation
would break.
If your system-- if you
cannot, with feedback,
drive your system so that
x is at the fixed point,
then the LQR cost function
will accumulate cost forever
and blow up.
So really, the first
thing, before we apply LQR,
we better take a
second to decide
if we think the system can get
to the origin with feedback.
And that condition is
called controllability.
And controllability is
a very powerful concept.
And I want to make
sure you understand
the relationship
between controllability
and underactuation.
So the question is--
for this system,
the question is,
if I have my linear system
and I started in some initial
conditions that are non-0--
otherwise it's not
so interesting--
if my initial
conditions are non-0,
can I design a feedback
law, find some actions, u,
that will drive my system
to 0 in a finite time?
So more generally, the
definition of controllability
says--
let's say, x at 0 equals
some initial conditions
to x at some final time to be
some other initial conditions,
given unbounded actions
in a finite time.
So controllability
is actually the thing
we care about in life.
For nonlinear systems,
controllability is actually
incredibly hard to evaluate.
Most systems tend
to be controllable.
But it's a hard thing to
evaluate for nonlinear systems.
For linear systems,
we have all the tools
we could dream of to
evaluate the controllability
of the system.
So for linear controllability,
it's sufficient to say,
x, t final equals 0.
So a lot of times
for linear systems,
people just ask controllable--
say it's controllable
if I can drive my system from
any initial conditions to 0
in a finite time.
And because everything's
nice and linear,
that's actually-- that's
equivalent to the stronger
definition for linear systems.
In nonlinear systems,
you have to evaluate
every initial condition,
every final condition,
if you're not careful.
So what do you think?
If the system is
underactuated, then
do you think it can
be controllable?
If I choose some place,
some state for the Acrobot,
and I choose a
finite time, can you
design a controller, potentially
with really big actions,
that gets me there
in finite time?
AUDIENCE: No.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Tell me why.
Tell me why you say no.
AUDIENCE: Well, it can
[INAUDIBLE] you potentially
[INAUDIBLE] stabilize
for Acrobot.
So regardless of the fact,
which [INAUDIBLE] you
can reach that [? theta. ?]
RUSS TEDRAKE: But
there's nothing
to say I can't leave
that state and come back
in some very finite, very
small amount of time.
So you're saying, if
I ask you to go here
at some small amount of
time, and I start right here,
then I can't be there in
some small amount of time.
But what if I put in so much
actuation that I go like this
and I'm back there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] have
to stay in the final state?
RUSS TEDRAKE: No,
it does not have
to stay in the final state.
AUDIENCE: So
underactuated implies
that the local dimensionality
of the reachable state-space
is lower than the
full dimension, right?
So if you just shrink
your finite time
to an arbitrarily
small time, we won't
be able to reach states
outside that [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: I think that--
so this is exactly the point.
So what he said is, he says,
the underactuation is--
I'll use the word instantaneous.
It's an instantaneous
constraint on what you can do.
At any incident in time, I
can only produce accelerations
in a certain direction.
So how can I possibly,
in some-- if I
make my finite
time small enough,
how can I possibly get there?
Well, finite time is actually
different than 0 time.
And the actions can
potentially be huge.
But actually, most-- a lot
of the underactuated systems
are controllable.
So we'll see it carefully in
the linearization of this.
But actually, controllability--
if you get one thing out
of this lecture--
and I'm going to write
at the end of the lecture
again on the board--
there's a difference
between controllability
and underactuation.
A lot of the underactuated
systems are, in fact,
controllable.
And that's what makes--
gives us a few more things
to talk about in the class.
So let's see if I can
make that point to you.
So how do we talk
about controllability,
in a linear system even?
So what are the tools people
use for controllability
in a linear system?
If you used them, call them out.
Who's used
controllability tools?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There's the matrix
C times B, C times A, times B,
write it all out,
then find the rank.
Would that be true?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good, there's
a controllability matrix.
AUDIENCE: There's a
controllability Gramian,
I think.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Awesome, there's
a controllability Gramian,
which turns out to be
almost exactly the--
what came out of
our LQR derivation.
Those are the two big ones.
So there are
controllability matrices,
controllability Gramians.
I'm going to say
a minute about it.
But if you care about--
we can actually-- both
of those are a little bit
unintuitive, actually.
And the proofs are-- the proof
of the Gramian's not bad,
but the proof of the--
the derivation of the
controllability matrix
is a little bit of black magic.
So I decided instead to
let's do a simpler case where
we can actually understand it.
But it'll be a less
general result.
So let's look at the x dot
equals Ax plus Bu system.
I'm going to make
our derivation easier
by making an assumption
that the eigenvalues of A
are all unique.
If you're willing to
make that assumption,
we can see a lot of things.
The more general
derivations don't have that,
but require black magic.
OK, so if you remember, our
eigenvalue thing, an eigenvalue
means that multiplying
A times that
is just the same as
multiplying a scalar times n.
If I compose all the--
sorry, these are eigenvectors.
That's an eigenvalue.
If I compose them all
into a matrix form,
I can see A times V, where
V has all the eigenvectors
as columns, is equivalent to--
well, let's write it
like V times lambda,
where lambda is a
diagonal matrix, which has
lambda 1, lambda 2, and so on.
The cool thing about--
the reason we assume that
there's no repeated eigenvalues
is that it implies
that all of the--
eigenvalues are unique implies
that all the eigenvectors are
actually unique and that
they span the space.
And it implies that
V inverse exists.
As soon as you have
repeated eigenvalues,
you don't have that
simplification.
You have to do repeated
roots and things.
But in that
simplification, we can
switch to modal coordinates.
So let's-- if V is full
rank, then I can just change
coordinates from x through
V inverse to some other
coordinate system r.
Why is that a good idea?
That's a good idea, because
then r dot is just going to be--
so V inverse times x
dot, which is A times Vr.
That's just substituting
this into the x dot equals Ax
plus Bu.
But what's V inverse AV?
If you look at this, that's
just our diagonal matrix.
So on the eigen--
in the modal
decomposition, the systems
evolve without coupling.
I can write--
component-wise, I could say,
ri dot, the i-th component
is just lambda ir,
plus some contributions
from this guy.
So now I'm looking at my--
in these modal coordinates,
I'm saying that the
result of applying A--
this is the same
thing I wrote before.
This is the reason we can
make-- in these phase plots,
we can find the
eigenvectors and just
talk about the dynamics on
those eigenvectors, same thing.
It just says that,
on the eigenvectors,
the dynamics are
just the eigenvalues.
And then they've got
this impulse, this input
from the control actions.
So now let's think
about what it would
mean to be controllable
in this sense.
What kind of
conditions would you
want to say that the
system is controllable?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: We can
change r dot using u.
RUSS TEDRAKE: You can
change r dot to do
anything you want using u.
You'd like to be
able to say, make
it act like the eigenvalues were
arbitrarily fast, for instance,
or arbitrarily unstable, if you
chose to do something so silly.
So what is required to do that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] from
the [? beta ?] values.
There'd have to be some
non-0's [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Excellent.
OK, so imagine you only have
a single thing you're trying
to control and lots of inputs.
Then it should be sufficient
that, if any one of those betas
is non-0, that should be enough.
OK, now let's say you have
multiple things you're
trying to control.
You start having to worry
about whether you can use u
to control eigenvector
1 and eigenvector 2,
both at the same time.
But it turns out,
because we assumed
we're in the case of
distinct eigenvalues,
if you think really hard-- and
I will write a little bit more
about this-- but it
turns out it's still
OK to just have one thing
that can control you.
Because things are converging
at different rates,
it's actually sufficient
to be able to control--
if you can control each
of them independently,
then you can actually
control them all.
So the condition turns
out to be, for all i,
there exists a j, such that
beta ij is not equal to 0.
Beta ij, again, is my B
matrix, but also permutated
by this V inverse.
So if I was looking at whether
the system was underactuated,
if B wasn't full
rank, I'd be hosed.
I'd be underactuated.
But this is actually a
much less strict condition.
I say, I only have to have
one of my-- in my eigen modes,
I have to be able to
control each of them.
So that's our first
sort of glimpse
at how you could imagine an
underactuated system being
completely controllable.
AUDIENCE: Is it
the same as saying
that, if you have
[? any ?] dimension
that you want to control,
then beta should have at least
n different eigenvalues?
[INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: So excellent--
so this actually says--
for instance, in
the limit, let's
take the case where you
have 100 degrees of freedom
and one actuator.
As long as Bij is non-0 for
all of those, then it says,
with my one actuator,
I could control--
I can drive that 100 degree of
freedom system to the origin.
That's a great question,
a great example.
So it does not have that
same rank condition on B.
AUDIENCE: So as long as
none of your eigenvectors
are in the null
space [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Right.
It's the-- I have to think
about what V inverse is,
but I think that's right.
I think that's right.
He said-- so you
don't want B to be
in the null space
of the inverse.
Right.
Do I see another
question over there?
No?
OK, so 100 degree of
freedom robot, one actuator,
there's a chance that
you can control it.
Now it doesn't say anything
about the trajectory you're
going to take to get there.
It might be really hard.
But there's a chance
you can control it.
There's lots of
ways to see this.
Let's leave it at that, if
people are satisfied with that.
Let's not-- I won't do my
second derivation here.
But let's get straight
to the example.
So now, that says that,
if I take my Ax plus Bu
representation of the Acrobot,
B is going to be low rank.
It's going to be--
so I used B actually
twice already today.
Did you notice that?
Anybody catch me on that?
I used B in the
manipulate equations,
then I used B for
the block form.
And I swear I've lost
sleep trying to figure out
if I could put another
letter in there,
but I'm not happy with
any other letters,
because they both-- they
almost mean the same thing.
But I did slip that one past.
So this is B in the linear form.
So it's not just 0, 1.
It's H inverse times 0, 1.
So it's going to have some 0's.
Sorry, it doesn't-- so it's
going to be a vector again.
It actually doesn't
have to have 0's.
And in fact, it
probably won't have 0's.
I misspoke.
This is going to be H1, 1, H1,
2 in the Acrobot case, H inverse
1, 1.
The question is-- it's still
low rank because it's a column.
It's not a full matrix, so
it's still underactuated.
And can I drive that
thing with LQR to the top?
We just said that it's possible
that these things are still
controllable.
The tests that you can
use, the user's guide
to controllability--
there's this funky
test which says,
if I take a matrix, a
controllability matrix, which
is the B matrix, AB--
these are just cascaded
in columns here,
A squared B up to
the A to the n, B,
where n is the number of states.
AUDIENCE: Would it be n minus 1?
[INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: n minus
1-- thank you, yeah.
Good, yeah.
It turns out that if
this matrix is still--
is full row rank, then the
system is controllable.
There's actually--
the derivation
of that is in your
notes that I'll post.
It's not very hard,
it's just a matter--
there's all these forms for e to
the AT, the matrix exponential.
And it involves one of the
forms that kind of comes out
of nowhere.
And so I won't go through
the derivation on the board.
But it turns out that
it's sufficient to check
the rank of this matrix.
And that'll tell you if
the system's controllable.
And this is sort of primal
enough and important enough
that MATLAB has a
function for it.
So you can call--
I think it's ctrb, right?
Is that what it is?
And then check the
rank of it, and you
could check if your
systems are controllable.
It turns out, if you linearize
the dynamics of the Acrobot,
you linearize the
dynamics of the cart-pole,
you pop in the A and B, you
get a full rank matrix out.
So they're both controllable,
even though they're
underactuated around the top.
AUDIENCE: Would these
be in [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes.
It's the linear form.
Maybe I should call it B
prime or something like that.
But still, it feels
unnatural to use either--
anything else in either case.
AUDIENCE: So these
matrices are calculated
for every single point, or--
RUSS TEDRAKE: So I just do it--
I evaluate these things
once at the x star.
So it's partial f, partial
x, evaluated at x star.
AUDIENCE: So when
you say something--
a system is controllable,
because when we--
RUSS TEDRAKE: All
I mean is that--
all I can show with the rank
condition check in MATLAB
is that the system linearized--
the linear system that
approximates the Acrobot
linearized around the top
is controllable.
Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: So controllability
is defined [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: No,
controllability
is a property of the system.
The linearization,
the linear system
is only a relevant approximation
of the Acrobot around a given
state.
And I'm saying that
the linear system--
you can evaluate the
linear system anywhere
it's controllable.
I can go from any
initial condition.
But it's only a
relevant example--
it's only relevant
to the Acrobot
if it's close to
the fixed point.
AUDIENCE: So that definition
actually is for all the states.
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's right.
So yes, if I can
say this stronger
thing for the nonlinear
system, for the Acrobot,
in order to say that, I would
have to say, for any state,
this is true.
I can't say that.
I went to a weaker
form by looking just
at the linear system.
Mm-hmm.
That's pretty big.
Is that big enough?
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah?
OK.
So let's take our
A and B matrices
that we got from doing the
linearization around the fixed
point.
And if you like, if it
helps, I can sort of
show you how that goes.
So very literally, I take
my manipulator equations,
I get an H, C, G, and B.
I take the gradient--
the partial G, partial
q, I compute that.
And then my A is negative
inverse partial G, partial q.
And then the--
C happens to be 0
for the Acrobot.
I evaluated at the top,
but that's not a general,
so that's why I don't have the
negative H inverse C there,
and then my inverse H, B. So
that gives me an A and a B.
And I can write
my LQR controller
to balance it at the
top, by literally getting
a and B from the linearized
system, calling LQR.
I chose-- the LQR
syntax is A, B, q, r.
So I chose q to be a diagonal
matrix, 10, 10, 1, 1,
just saying I penalize
position errors
10 times more than velocity
errors because it happens--
with units, you tend to do that.
And r is 1.
And it's in a persistent loop
just so I don't compute--
I don't call LQR every
time I call my function.
I only call it every
time I start the system.
And then my control
law is u equals
negative k, x minus x desired.
Now, you're going to do
sort of the similar thing
to what I'm doing for
the Acrobot you're
going to do for the cart-pole
for your problem set.
I will bet that half of you
will forget to subtract out
x desired at least once.
I know I do all the time.
So remember the minus x desired.
If I put that at
the top, if I put
initial conditions near
the top, and I run it,
look what happens.
Oops.
OK, I'm going to
start it-- every time
it flashes it's going to
be new initial condition.
It actually goes pretty far
from the top and gets back.
Wow, that's a good one.
If I-- I'm just choosing
Gaussian random variables
at the top.
So if we watch long
enough, we might
see one fail catastrophically.
So the LQR for the linear
system will stabilize it
from any point because
the linear system
is a bad approximation.
For the nonlinear, if I started
it way down at the bottom
it's just going to go nuts.
Wow, that's pretty good.
Now, you might notice that
my second link is pretty big
compared to my first link.
That helps.
And you'll see why
in a few minutes.
But it's pretty good.
AUDIENCE: Does it
have unbounded torque?
RUSS TEDRAKE: It does
have unbounded torque.
Whoa.
[LAUGHTER] That's pretty good.
It does have
unbounded torque, yep.
If I were to
saturate the torque,
it probably wouldn't do as well.
Now, the cool thing is--
I can stop that.
Stop.
These MATLAB timers
don't like to stop.
So I get these huge
excursions from the upright
in my balancing.
But it's not actually
because I started
with crazy initial conditions.
If you noticed, it
wasn't like the plot
was going, oh, and starting
over here and then coming up.
It was actually going like this.
So if you look at
a time trajectory--
let's see if I got lucky.
OK, almost all of
them are like this.
Are those lines
dark enough to see?
Yeah?
The initial conditions
are actually pretty small.
But in order to
stabilize the system,
it actually goes way
away from the fixed point
and comes way back, big time.
This is like-- this is
the velocity of 18 radians
per second or something.
And then it finds its way back.
So for that reason, you
might easily sort of, in LQR,
say, OK, my linearization
is good here,
so any initial conditions
here should work.
But that's not actually true
because your LQR might easily
drive you further away
before it comes back.
If you were to-- if you're
a linear controls guy,
and you were to do-- this is
a multi-input, multi-output
system.
But if you try to find
the poles and 0's, that's
what's this going to--
where are the 0's--
is this going to be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah,
there's three 0's
in the right f plane for
the Acrobot actually.
It's a nonminimum phase system.
The cart-pole has one
0 in the right f plane.
It's not a general property
of underactuated systems.
But sometimes, in order to
do this with less actuators
than you might like, you have
to do crazy things to get back
to where you want to go.
So I can get-- and I could--
if I tightened my time limit,
the things I would do
would be even crazier.
But I could still do it.
It's actually-- just to say
it, without really teaching it,
but if you did care about sort
of the basin of attraction
of these systems, if you wanted
to do as well as you possibly
could with a linear controller
on the nonlinear system,
you probably wouldn't
do what we just did.
There's better tools from
robust control, which
would allow you to sort of
design a linear controller
but explicitly reason about
how nonlinear the thing
gets when you're away.
And you can design
a linear controller
that has a bigger
basin of attraction
than if you just don't reason
about the nonlinearities
at all.
So you can put a bound on how
nonlinear things are and do
a robust control
synthesis, and get,
in some sense, a
better controller.
You would have lower
performance, potentially,
but it would work better
on the nonlinear system,
bigger basin of attraction.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Oh, my fixed
point was pi 0, 0, 0.
Or-- yeah.
So those are all going to
0, that one's going to pi,
as they should.
Yep.
OK, excellent.
So LQR works, right?
And it works-- this is actually
sort of a problem, in my mind.
Because that works and
it works so well And so
many different
systems, that's why
people haven't thought about
nonlinear control enough,
in my mind.
It's sort of unfortunate
that that works so darn well,
because sometimes
that's all people do.
So let's think about if we're
a little bit further from
the fixed point, just to-- maybe
I should even make the point--
in other words, you'll probably
ask me if I don't do this,
because you always test
me on the limits of where
my things work here.
So what if I were to start it
far away from the fixed point?
Let's be more dramatic.
And let's just do it once.
Oh, see, that's bad.
When it takes that
long, that means
the integrator's choking because
it can't simulate things right.
So it's just complete
nonsense if it's too far
from the linearization point.
So what if we want to do control
away from that fixed point?
Then nothing I just said
helps if I'm too far away
from that fixed point.
So what do we do?
Well, you don't have to throw
out linearization completely.
We talked about, in
the first lecture,
how the underactuated
systems are the systems that
are not feedback linearizable.
That's what distinguishes them.
They're not feedback
linearizable.
I can't just turn the nonlinear
system into a linear system.
But they are partial
feedback linearizable.
So if you want to
stick to your guns
and do feedback linearization,
you can do half the work.
So it actually is pretty
elegant how that works out.
OK, to keep things fresh, let's
do it on the cart-pole instead
of the Acrobot.
We've been talking
about the Acrobot a lot.
But I promise I wasn't
going to do the derivation
of the equations of
motion, and I won't.
But it turns out the
result of the cart-pole
is simple enough I can
write it real quick.
The equations of motion for
the cart-pole are mc plus mp.
And these are in your notes.
You don't have to
write these down.
I want you to see where
the next line comes from.
OK, well, that's
a reasonable thing
we might get out of
the Lagrange equations.
I've got a force on my cart.
I've got a 0 in
the other equation.
You can see how this
could be easily separated
into the manipulator equations.
But since I'm going
to be manipulating
some of these things, let
me just sort of arbitrarily
set all the parameters to 1.
Let's just-- so--
it's easy to repeat these
for the real equations.
But let's just do this.
And I'll get a 2x double dot
plus theta double dot, c,
which is cosine
theta-- c is enough--
minus theta dot
squared s equals f.
OK, and then x double dot c,
plus theta double dot, plus x
equals 0.
Now, those I can work with.
AUDIENCE: It says G [INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah, that's
just to save my handwriting.
It's not to be
physically accurate.
It doesn't change the
structure of the equations.
If you like, you could set--
I bet I could come up with
a parameterization which
would keep G at around
10 and do OK, but--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: There
you go, there you go.
OK, so given these equations,
can I make x double
dot and theta double
dot do whatever I want?
So no.
We said that the feedback
linearization trick required
that B inverse, in general.
And so we couldn't do that.
But it turns out I
can do something.
So what are these equations?
This is a cart moving around
with a pendulum on it.
And I'm pushing the cart, and
the pendulum's dangling away.
So what would feedback
linearization--
what would a partial
feedback linearization mean?
Well, if I know the
dynamics of the pendulum
and I know the state
of the pendulum,
and I can control
the force on my cart,
then it's pretty reasonable
to think that I could--
whatever force the
pendulum was applying
to push my cart around, I could
just exactly cancel that out.
So I could turn my cart
dynamics to sort of just
do whatever I want and
just cancel out the effect
that that pendulum's
adding to me.
That seems reasonable.
And that's called a collocated
partial feedback linearization.
I'm going to write
PFL from now on.
It's collocated because the
state I'm trying to linearize
is the same one where
the actuator is sitting.
It's collocated.
The state I'm linearizing is
collocated with my actuators.
So my goal is to make x double
dot have the dynamics, whatever
dynamics I choose-- x double
dot desired, let's say.
So let's see if we can
do this by manipulating
the equations a little bit.
OK, so I can figure out how x
double dot and theta double dot
are related with
that second equation.
So let's get rid of
theta double dot.
I can see theta double dot had
better be negative x double
dot c minus s.
And if I insert that
into the first equation,
then I get 2x double dot
minus x double dot, c minus s.
Oops.
Minus sc minus theta
dot squared s equals f.
That means, if I
apply the control law,
2 minus c squared, x
double dot desired,
minus sc minus
theta dot desired s,
that implies that x double dot
equals x double dot desired,
like we wanted.
And theta double dot ends
up doing something coupled.
But that's sort of the
resulting dynamics.
I didn't actually plan for that.
That's just whatever I got out.
Does that make sense?
That's just me saying--
if you think about
the controller
here, that's just
taking the terms that
Are going to be contributed to
the dynamics by the pendulum
and canceling them
out by applying
exactly the opposite forces.
And the result is that my
x moves exactly however I
want it to do.
So feedback
linearization isn't dead
if you have an
underactuated system.
But you can't feedback
linearize the whole system.
You can do this collocated
feedback linearization.
Now, the cooler thing
is, you can actually,
often, also feedback
linearize the passive joint.
So it's pretty
logical that I could
move the cart in such a way
that I can't allow the pendulum
dynamics.
It's a little less
intuitive that I
can make the
pendulum dynamics do
whatever I want with the cart.
But you can, most of the time.
OK, so non-collocated
means I'm going to use one
of my actuators to control--
feedback linearize one
of my passive joints.
So now let's see if we can make
theta double dot do whenever
we--
bend to our will.
It turns out the manipulation
is almost exactly the same.
Algebraically,
it's not surprising
that I can do either one.
I've got my equations
of motion here.
I've got-- both x double
dot and theta double
depend on my force.
And they're coupled here.
So sure, I can control
either one of them.
Physically, it's a
little less intuitive.
But algebraically,
it's just as obvious.
OK, so let's just
do the opposite one.
So x double dot had better
be theta double dot,
plus s over c, that
whole thing negative,
based on that second equation.
And so I get 2 over
c, theta double
dot plus s, negative on
there, plus theta double
dot c, minus theta
dot squared c--
oops, s-- sorry-- equals f.
Yeah, so sure, so if I apply
f equals is the controller--
what's the best way to
write this? c minus 2
over c, theta
double dot, desired,
minus theta dot squared s.
Is that right?
AUDIENCE: Minus 2 SOC from
the first [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good, yes.
Minus 2 tan theta.
Good, thank you.
Cool.
So that's a much less
intuitive result, I think.
But it's a much
more powerful one.
It says, if I wanted to directly
control the pendulum, I can.
I have to give up something.
x double dot, then, is
going to end up being--
the resulting motion of the
cart could be a little strange.
It's going to be whatever this
theta double dot desired plus s
over c looks like.
But who cares?
If I'm just trying to keep
the cart up, that's OK.
In your 6003 type
demos, they also
worry about not running into
the rails, which is important.
But to first order,
this is a good thing.
What did I gloss over?
AUDIENCE: Theta
goes to pi over 2.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah, right?
So I put a cosine on the
bottom here without being
careful about that.
So what is that?
What is that
physically related to?
AUDIENCE: If your pendulum
goes flat, then [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Exactly.
When my pendulum is directly
sideways, then suddenly,
nothing I do with
the cart is going
to control the accelerations
of that pendulum.
So instantaneously, you lose
the ability to control that.
If you're going to swing up
from the bottom to the top,
then you go through that.
So who cares?
So stop doing
control for a second,
and then you'll
get back to a place
where you can control it again.
So that sort of says
everything, I think,
that your intuition should
relate about these things.
And then for the Acrobot, it's
sort of similarly surprising,
but I can use my elbow torque to
feedback linearize my shoulder
torque--
same thing.
So if I wanted to make
it do whatever I want,
really, then I can do that.
I might have to spin like
crazy or do something nuts.
But I can make my passive
joint do whatever I want.
It's kind of cool.
In fact, just to--
I want to show the slightly
more general derivation of that
or form of that, but
just to make the point.
So one of the ways we've been
playing with Little Dog--
this is our robotic dog.
So Little Dog has actuators
at all the internal joints.
It's got-- if you're just
looking at it from the side,
all you care about, it's got
one in the knee, it's got,
actually, two in the hip--
but that doesn't matter here--
two in the other
hip, one in the knee.
But the thing we're
about to make it do
is try to control the dynamics
around the foot, which
is just like the Acrobot.
It doesn't-- the place where
you might think you'd want it
the most is where you
don't have the actuator.
So if you want to do something
like this with your dog,
then you've got a reason
about the coupling,
the inertial coupling,
which is what we did here,
that allows you to decide--
the slipping at the end is ugly
and we didn't do that right.
But until the impact, we did
a pretty good job, actually,
of regulating the
position of the dog,
just using the controlled
actuators and where our most
essential variable was passive.
It took a slightly
more general form,
which I'm going to show you
on Thursday, to do that.
But partial feedback
linearization
is sort of alive and well
and useful in robotics.
Let me just--
I'll show you half of the--
or one of the slightly more
general derivations of it,
just because it's so easy with
this algebra manipulation.
So let's say I have manipulator
equations of the form--
I'm just going to lump C, q
dot, and G into a single term
because they don't affect
the derivation at all.
And let's say that
I've stacked--
I've reordered my
equations of motion
so that all of my
passive joints are on top
and all my actuated
joints are on the bottom.
So these are all matrices.
Let me call q1, the
collection-- it's
a vector of all
the passive joints,
and q2 all the active joints.
Then if I break this
up just a little bit,
I can write the
same equation as--
as that.
I left these up
the whole lecture
thinking I was going to
point to them all the time--
never did.
I'm going to erase them now.
OK, so what is my
collocated form?
Collocated means I'm going
to try to control q2.
So let's solve for--
q1 is going to be H1,
1, inverse, H1, 2,
q2 double dot plus phi 1.
Am I allowed to do
that, H1, 1, inverse?
It takes a little bit of
thinking, but it's actually OK.
It's a positive
definite matrix H.
So it turns out the square
diagonal entries are actually
also have to be
positive definite.
So maybe take my word on that.
And then I can plug that in
and see that, if I do tau--
let's see if I can just
do it in the step here.
Tau is going to have
to be H2, 2, plus--
no, I missed a minus, didn't I?
q1 is-- I missed
a minus in here.
Minus H1, 1, H1, 2--
I did that.
I should have done
it in two steps.
It's H2, 1, H1, 1, inverse,
H1, 2, q2 double dot desired,
plus phi 2.
Right?
In the non-collocated,
we're going
to have to solve
for q2 double dot.
That's going to be H1, 2,
negative H1, 2, inverse,
times H1, 1, q1 double
dot, plus theta 1.
I missed my theta 1
term in here somewhere.
That should have
been also in here.
Yeah.
OK, so the first step in the
non-collocated, in general,
is this H1, 2 inverse.
Is that one OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Not necessarily.
I could have had
a different number
of actuated active and
passive degrees of freedom.
So let me write something
that's a little bit better,
the sort of pseudo inverse.
And what matters--
the non-collocation,
the partial feedback
linearization
is going to work if and only
if that matrix is full row
rank again.
So what does that mean?
It means I can't use one
active degree of freedom
to control two or more
passive degrees of freedom.
I need to have at least as many
actuators as degrees of freedom
I'm going to try to control.
That's reasonable.
But it's a little bit
more than that still.
I actually have to have
them inertially coupled
in the right way.
So if I had two
pendula on the table--
well, the table might
have some dynamics.
If I had two pendula bolted to
completely independent bases,
and I had an actuator on one and
not an actuator on the other,
that ain't gonna work.
I can't make any math that's
going to make that work.
So there has to be some inertial
coupling between the two.
So the rank condition on
this is the condition of--
is sometimes called
the condition
of strong inertial coupling.
The strong means that it's
uniformly inertially coupled.
It's just inertially
coupled in some state.
And if for all q this
thing is full rank,
then it's strong
inertial coupling.
And there's even a
more general form.
So in general, you can--
and what we do in
Little Dog is, we
pick some combination of
actuated and unactuated degrees
of freedom.
And actually, what we care about
is a virtual degree of freedom,
which is the center of mass.
And I'll show you at the
beginning of the next lecture
the most general form of this.
But I can't put up
these PFL equations
without spending one
minute at the end saying,
PFL is still sort of bad, right?
I don't really-- it
works, and I use it
because I want to
control these robots.
But I don't like
feedback linearization.
Feedback linearization is bad.
This is taking some beautiful
nonlinear system that
has beautiful equations
and arbitrarily
pumping in some potentially
large amount of energy
to squish those dynamics
and bend them to your will.
And that's good.
That's the feedback way.
But it's not the only way.
So we do it when we have to.
But it's better if you don't.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't you
have [INAUDIBLE] errors
in the [INAUDIBLE]?
RUSS TEDRAKE: It
could be that, if you
don't have the model
perfect, that you
could be doing bad things too.
Any time you have large
control gains going around,
you're going to be sensitive.
So don't always do this.
But I do want you to know
that you can do this if you so
choose to take that path.
OK, cool, so on Thursday we
will use these partial feedback
linearizations and
LQR together to make
the Acrobot, the cart-pole
swing up and balance.
If all goes well and we don't
have any License Manager
issues, then we'll
see it in class.